James Carranza has tried to kill himself
three times when he was born it wasn't
clear to doctors or his parents if he
was male or female and so he says a
childhood of misery began but he says
some things have since improved for
intersex people here in Kenya the
government is now conducting a census is
the first in Africa to recognize
intersex people as an alternative to
typical males and females there was a
realization that intersex children are
being killed most of these children
cannot even access our simple our
government services then there was a
need to have policies that look or own
to intersex species another group to be
recognized for the first time in this
census the people with albinism it's now
listed as a disability because it will
make us to count it will make us to be
seen to be Kenyans it is validates us
that we are actually a demographic
variable within the mosaic of the Kenyan
population the government hopes most of
the data can be collected into evenings
in the last census 10 years ago some
officials were accused of rigging
politics in Kenya her often contested
along tribal lines and census data
determines the allocation of state
resources no people are trying to do
some funny games asking people to move
this way or that way we are watching you
and at an appropriate time we will
ensure that you meet with the law
collecting accurate data is a challenge
about 10 million Kenyans and nomadic
herders who regularly cross borders to
neighboring countries millions more live
in slums like this one there's no
official list of addresses so the
government has ordered bars and pubs to
close and told everyone to stay home and
wait for the enumerators to come and
knock at the door
they push the data collection takes days
processing it takes much longer
what is so Morrison's nationality the
results might contain some surprises or
be contested Kenyans will have to wait
months to find out
Malcolm web al-jazeera Nairobi Kenya